Welcome to our table today as we open Reza Shah Kazemi's spiritual ethos to uncover the Imam's teaching on the remembrance of God and to deeply examine why the very simplest act of worship is designated as the absolute greatest.
God has made the remembrance a polish for the hearts by which they hear after being deaf and see after being blind.
It is such a profound starting point.
It really is.
And
Our mission in this deep dive is to trace the contours of what tikr truly means, to examine the foundations of why it outranks every other right, and to uncover how exactly a polished heart comes to see God.
Well, we have a lot of ground to cover.
We do, but I mean we actually have to begin by confronting A profound paradox that is planted at the very center of Islamic spirituality.
I want you to consider the sheer physical endurance demanded by the traditional pillars of worship.
Like, think of the fasting month.
Oh, sure.
The believer abstains from food and water from dawn until dusk, which historically and even today in many parts of the world means enduring scorching heat, intense physical fatigue, and just the deep visceral ache of hunger.
It is an undeniable, grueling physical tool.
It is.
And then consider almsgiving, which requires the parting of hard-earned wealth.
I mean, this cuts directly into our deepest human attachments to security and comfort.
And just the basic anxiety of survival, Precisely.
You are quite literally giving away your earthly security.
It is a profound material sacrifice.
Yes.
And then, consider the pilgrimage.
Historically, this demanded A treacherous months-long journey across unforgiving deserts.
An undertaking completely fraught with peril, bandits, disease.
Immense financial expense.
People would actually write their wills before they left because survival was not guaranteed.
I see.
Even the fixed daily prayers demand specific times that interrupt sleep and commerce.
They require rigid postures and strict ritual purity, sometimes involving washing with freezing water in the depths of winter.
Every single one of these pillars commands a heavy, undeniable toll in time, wealth, or physical exertion.
Yet the tradition singles out an act that costs no money, requires no journey, demands no physical exhaustion, and can be performed while simply walking through a marketplace, sitting in a chair or eating a meal.
The bare silent turning of the heart and tongue toward the Creator is called the greatest of all works.
I don't buy that yet.
How can the easiest act of worship outrank fasting, charity, and battle?
I mean, it seems entirely counterintuitive to human nature.
We operate on an economy of effort, you know.
We do.
We just assume that the value of an action is strictly proportional to the suffering or the effort required to execute it.
in our physical lives, in our careers, in our societies.
We believe that if you do not sweat, you do not earn the prize.
If I exhaust my body in fasting or give away half my life savings, the tangible sacrifice is undeniable.
To claim that simply turning the mind or the tongue toward God supersedes those immense physical, material, and mortal sacrifices, it requires A monumental justification.
It sounds almost too convenient.
That friction is entirely necessary.
I mean, we are conditioned from childhood to measure value by the sweat on our brow or the ache in our muscles.
Definitely.
If it does not hurt, we just assume it is not working.
But to resolve this paradox, we must journey inward.
We must move past the outward societal consequences of worship to uncover what remembrance actually does to the hidden microscopic depths of a human being.
Okay, I'm listening.
Fasting starves the physical body.
Almsgiving starves the ego's greed.
But these actions, noble and foundational as they are, act upon the perimeter of the human condition.
They manage the borders.
Precisely.
We are searching for the root.
We are looking for the practice that acts directly upon the center of consciousness itself.
So where do we find that center?
To find it, we must look to the source of this teaching.
We turn to the Imam, peace be upon him.
He stands at the head of the entire mystical tradition.
Throughout history, he is recognized as the gate to the city of prophetic wisdom.
His presence marks every noble expression of the spirit within this faith.
Even the ancient craft guilds, the leather workers, the masons, the blacksmiths, they trace their codes of spiritual chivalry back to his teachings.
His influence really spans from the grit of the marketplace all the way to the highest, most refined expressions of poetry and art.
It does.
His teachings form an organic, load-bearing bridge.
He takes the early scriptural verses regarding remembrance
and distills them, foreshadowing the elaborate complex doctrines that later mystics would spend centuries constructing.
And from this point forward, we will simply refer to him as the Imam.
I see.
And his position as a unifying figure is truly singular in the history of religion.
Very much so.
When we examine the historical development of these spiritual paths, we see a tradition that is profoundly shared and reverent.
I mean, the Imam unites what is often perceived as the esoteric core of the religion.
This core expresses itself distinctly through Sunni Sufism and Sheet
Two streams that history sometimes paints as divergent.
But they aren't, really.
No, because the great unifier taught a principle that completely collapses those historical boundaries.
He argued that true followers of the imams are inherently walking the mystical path, and concurrently, true mystics are deeply rooted in the teachings of the imams.
The outward historical differences, the sectarian lines drawn by politicians and dynasties, are entirely dissolved in the fire of sanctity and gnosis.
That dissolution is vital.
We are not looking at a fractured philosophy.
We are looking at a shared, unified human inheritance.
We are.
But to grasp the magnitude of this inheritance, we must define the instrument itself.
We need to establish what remembrance actually means in this context, because our modern vocabulary really betrays us here.
How so?
Well, the lexicographer offers a definition that cuts through our modern misconceptions.
He writes that remembrance is not merely memory.
It is that by which a person keeps present the knowledge they have attained.
Oh, I see.
This is the critical hinge of our entire discussion.
It is not the act of storing a fact away in the brain, like filing a document in a dusty cabinet to be retrieved later.
It is the active, intense, relentless process of rendering a known reality vividly present to consciousness here and now.
The distinction between passive memory and rendering something present is massive.
I mean, memory as we typically experience it is entirely passive and retrospective.
True.
You recall a childhood home or the date of a historical battle or just where you parked your car.
The information is retrieved from cold storage, observed briefly by the mine and then put back.
It has no bearing on your immediate state of being.
Definitely not.
But the lexicographer is describing an active burning presencing.
It is the difference between knowing intellectually that the sun is a star millions of miles away and standing directly in a desert at noon, blinded by its light and feeling its heat blister your skin.
Now that is a perfect way to put it.
You are not retrieving A theological concept of a distant creator.
You are pulling the reality of the divine into the immediate overwhelming foreground of your awareness.
Furthermore, possesses this fascinating dual nature.
It is simultaneously the end and the means.
The end and the means.
Yes.
It is the ultimate spiritual awareness itself, the final destination of the seeker.
And it is the methodic, rigorous discipline used to cultivate that very awareness.
It is the hammer, the anvil, and the sword all at once.
You invoke the name to achieve the state of invocation.
That dual nature explains a great deal about why it permeates the tradition so thoroughly.
You practice the act of presencing to achieve a state of continuous presence.
Precisely.
But if this practice is the core, if it is the ultimate foundation, how does it escape the boundaries that confine all those other rituals we discussed earlier?
Well, it escapes those boundaries precisely because it is commanded without a ceiling.
Without a ceiling, okay.
Look at the architecture of the other rites.
We exist in a world that loves boundaries and checklists.
The daily prayers are strictly numbered.
There are 5, not 50.
Fasting is bounded by the dawn and dusk of a single specific month.
Pilgrimage is required, ideally just once in a lifetime.
These are finite obligations.
You can complete them, check the box, and say, I have done my duty.
Remembrance alone is commanded in the imperative without any limitation.
The scripture tells the believer to remember with much remembrance.
It is the singular work you are told never to have done enough of.
There is no finish line.
There is no quota.
If this demands A perpetual state of presence and deep retreat,
Isn't that just an escape from the demands and duties of the real world?
How do you mean?
Well, it paints a picture of a practitioner locked away in a dark room, severing all ties with society, family, and civic duty solely to maintain this unbroken stream of consciousness.
It sounds like an invasion of the human condition rather than an elevation of it.
I see.
If the greatest act of worship requires me to ignore my neighbors and abandon my responsibilities, that seems deeply flawed.
I understand the concern and it is actually.
a common critique of mystical traditions, but the tradition anticipates it perfectly.
The retreat, as noted by the modern scholar of Nostros, is indeed a method.
It is a temporary isolation required to build capacity.
Like a training ground.
Just like that, you retreat to the quiet room to forge the discipline, to learn the heavy lifting of the mind without the distraction of the world pulling at your senses.
But the ultimate goal is not to stay in that room.
The great reviver theologian highlights that the true aim is a continuous presence of heart that dignifies and strengthens every other act in the world.
The goal is to carry that intense inward silence into the loud, chaotic marketplace.
The goal is to strike the anvil, trade the goods, sign the contracts, and feed the poor, all while the heart remains anchored in the uninterrupted presence of the real.
It does not negate the world.
It transforms the mundane world into a theater of worship.
I see.
The integration into daily life elevates the concept entirely.
It ceases to be an act of monastic avoidance and becomes an act of radical engagement.
It truly does.
You are engaging with the material world, dealing with difficult people, managing crises, but you are operating from a fortified, luminous center.
You are no longer swept away by the current of daily anxieties because you are tethered to something immovable.
Which brings us to the verdict of the Prophet, peace and blessings of a lobby upon
him and his family.
And from here, we will just refer to him as the prophet.
Okay.
He posed a profound question to his companions, asking if he should tell them of the best and purest of their works.
He stated it is more exalted than giving away mountains of gold and silver, better even than meeting the enemy in battle and striking their necks or having one's own neck struck.
My goodness.
And the answer he gave them was the perpetual invocation of God.
To emphasize the absolute gravity of this, he offered a stark, terrifying image.
He said the likeness of the one who remembers their Lord and the one who does not remember him is the likeness of the living and the dead.
The living and the dead.
We must dwell deeply on this reality.
To be heedless is not just to be...
a negligent practitioner or a slightly flawed human being.
It is to be a corpse that walks.
The physical body may be exceptionally busy.
It may be accumulating vast wealth, fighting literal or corporate battles, building massive monuments, or just endlessly scrolling through meaningless noise.
But the spiritual pulse has completely stopped.
The inner life is entirely extinct.
The walking dead.
It is a chilling extrapolation.
We define life biologically by a heartbeat, by respiration, by brainwave activity.
If those metrics are present, we declare a person alive.
Sure.
This analogy demands a spiritual definition of life that makes our biological metrics look superficial.
I mean, a person can have a perfectly functioning cardiovascular system, a sharp intellect, and a vibrant social life, yet be entirely deceased in the realm that actually matters.
Completely deceased.
The body is a functioning machine, but the occupant is gone.
The heedless person interacts with the world merely as a collision of matter.
They see a tree as timber, they see a person as a resource or an obstacle, completely blind to the underlying
that sustains their very existence.
They are sleepwalking through a miraculous existence, confusing the dream for reality.
And the ultimate tragedy of the walking corpse is that it does not know it is dead.
It feels the warmth of the sun on its skin.
It tastes sweet food.
It feels the rush of adrenaline, and it thinks it is fully alive.
It has no idea what it's missing.
It is entirely ignorant of the greater light, the profound oceanic reality it is missing.
It is like a person born in a lightless cave who thinks the damp walls are the extent of the universe.
This establishes the dire necessity of the spiritual pulse.
But we must understand the mechanism of revival.
How does a corpse wake up?
How does a blinded organ learn to see again?
God has made the remembrance a polish for the hearts by which they hear after being deaf and see after being blind.
The rusted mirror burnish clean.
This provides the physical mechanism of the practice.
It does.
The heart in this tradition is not the blood pumping muscle in the chest, nor is it the seat of mere fluctuating emotion.
It is an organ of deep, profound perception.
It is the spiritual center of the human being, the cognitive core where intellect and spirit merge.
I see.
Currently for The Walking Dead, this organ is thickly clouded by rust.
The rust is forgetfulness.
It is the accumulation of daily distractions, the unchecked ego, the minor and major sins,
Layer by layer, day by day, this oxidation builds up until the mirror is completely opaque.
Remembrance is the rigorous, abrasive rubbing away of that rust.
Let us dissect the etymology of the word polish as used by the imam in this context.
The root word implies a becoming clear and exposing to view, a bringing into the open.
It is the same linguistic root used to describe the break of day when it finally brings the sun to light.
banishing the darkness.
So you are not painting a new picture on the heart.
No.
You are not acquiring some foreign alien knowledge.
You are furiously, diligently scraping away the accumulated grime to reveal what is already there.
The physical effort implied by polishing is incredibly telling.
I mean, burnishing a deeply rusted sheet of metal is not a gentle, passive act.
It requires friction.
It requires consistent, repetitive force.
If you just lightly brush a rusted mirror with a soft cloth, nothing happens.
The practice of invocation, the endless repetition, is the friction against the rust.
It can be exhausting.
It forces the practitioner to confront the ugliness of their own distractions.
And the dual action of this mirror is profoundly beautiful.
On one side, the polished surface is cleared to reflect the truth coming down from above.
But it is not just a piece of passive glass waiting for an external beam.
Exactly.
I mean, definitely not.
The Persian poet offers imamate of breasts polished by invocation to receive the pure, unspotted image.
The clearing of the surface simultaneously uncovers buried treasures of the intellect latent within the heart itself.
The heart is remembering something it always inherently knew.
It possesses an ingrained primordial knowledge of the Creator.
The rust merely obscured this internal incandescence.
Correct.
The polish clears the window to the sky, yes, but it also excavates the luminous jewels buried in the floor of the soul.
But this leads us to the ultimate question of perception.
If the heart undergoes this rigorous burnishing, if the rust is cleared away through decades of
and the organ recovers its sight, what does it actually see?
The Imam provides an answer of breathtaking audacity.
When asked if he had seen his Lord, he states that the heart sees God.
That sounds like wordplay, if the heart sees God.
Isn't that just a feeling dressed up as sight?
I understand why you'd say that.
We use the word see metaphorically all the time in everyday language.
We say, I see what you mean to indicate comprehension.
We say, I see the logic in your argument.
We do.
To claim the heart literally sees the divine feels like taking a subjective emotional swell, an overwhelming feeling of peace or awe during meditation and dressing it up in the vocabulary of optical vision to make it sound more authoritative.
It sounds like poetry masquerading as literal truth.
It is entirely necessary to challenge that claim because without a massive epistemological shift, the claim collapses into absurdity.
We must avoid a fundamental category mistake.
Okay, lay it out for me.
The physical eye is strictly bound to the surfaces of the sensible world.
It is a biological instrument that registers photons bouncing off physical matter.
It cannot see justice, it cannot see love, it cannot see gravity, and it certainly cannot see the limitless non-material divine reality.
To expect the physical eye to see God is a flaw in basic logic.
It is like trying to measure the temperature of a room with a ruler.
I see.
The heart's sight is not empirical observation.
It does not measure wavelength or distance.
It sees through the verities of faith.
It is not the acquisition of a new data point.
It is the presencing of a reality.
When the heart is polished, it perceives the underlying truth that sustains all physical matter.
It perceives the real.
I follow the epistemological distinction.
We are talking about an organ designed to perceive a different dimension of reality entirely.
Just as the ear cannot perceive light, the physical eye cannot perceive the divine.
Precisely.
The spiritual heart is the specific receptor tuned to this frequency of existence.
And this brings us to a beautiful convergence.
There is a Quranic imagery the Imam was referencing when discussing the polish.
Light upon light.
Yes.
Imagine a lamp situated in a niche, enclosed in glass, lit from a blessed tree.
When all art is burnished, the latent inner light of the polished heart, the inherent primordial knowledge we discussed, rises up.
It ascends to meet the overarching descending light from on high.
The internal illumination and the external revelation meet and recognize each other.
It is light upon light.
The seer and the scene are illuminated by the same singular radiance.
The geometry of that image is striking.
Isn't it?
The niche contains and focuses the light, preventing it from dissipating into the void.
The polished heart becomes the niche.
It holds the latent light, tending it through disciplined remembrance, protecting it from the winds of distraction until it is pure enough to merge with the descending light.
But the paradox deepens still, and we must venture into the most profound territory of this teaching.
We turn to the concept explored by the early Sufi
The tradition teaches a stunning reality about the culmination of this path.
What is that?
Through intense, unbroken devotion, God becomes the very hearing by which the servant hears and the sight by which the servant sees.
If the divine enters into the outward acts of perception in this way, we face a staggering conclusion.
The supreme act of spiritual awareness, this ultimate vision of the heart, is not actually man's vision of God.
It is God's vision of God, affected through the purified space of the human heart.
Oh my goodness, I completely concede the magnitude of that.
It is a lot to take in.
It completely dismantles our standard framework of knowing.
I had viewed the seeker as the subject, looking outward at God as the object, like an astronomer
are looking at a star through a telescope.
But if God becomes the site itself, the dichotomy completely collapses.
It does.
I grasp the immensity of the Imam's command to know God through God.
You cannot build knowledge of the divine from below, stacking empirical facts like bricks to reach heaven.
No, you cannot.
True knowledge is the real coming to know itself within the cleared, polished space of the human subject.
The human being provides the burnished mirror, but the light that sees and the light that is seen are one and the same.
The concession is profound because it requires the ultimate surrender.
It is the surrender of the ego as the primary agent of knowledge.
The eye that demands to see God, the eye that wants to claim this spiritual trophy of enlightenment, must fade entirely, leaving only the polished mirror.
Now, we must ground this highly elevated, dizzying state back into the physical world you inhabit.
What does the person with the polished heart actually experience when they walk out of the retreat and into the blinding sun of the modern marketplace?
That is the ultimate test, isn't it?
Is.
The objective reality is that the purified heart sees the divine
attributes manifested everywhere.
The tree, the stone, the stranger's face, the falling rain.
Nothing that exists can be shut out of the divine reality.
Every single atom is recognized as a locus of manifestation for the real.
It transforms the mundane world into an unbroken landscape of revelation.
Every interaction, every glance becomes a reading of a divine text.
But there is a sheer theological cliff edge here.
I mean, if you see the divine in the tree or the stone, you risk sliding
to a simple pantheism.
You risk collapsing the creator into the created, treating the universe itself as God, which violates the core of the monotheistic vision.
Which is why the imam provides a critical, unbreakable safeguard.
He states that God is with everything, but not through association.
And he is other than everything, but not through separation.
I see.
This is the delicate, magnificent tension of imminence and transcendence.
He is closer to the human being than the jugular vein, permeating reality, yet he remains utterly incomparable and beyond all created things.
The polished heart holds these two truths in perfect unyielding balance.
It is the ultimate cognitive and spiritual endurance test.
To see the profound nearness without blending the two into a muddy pantheism, and to acknowledge the utter distance without losing the intimate connection to a distant watchmaker, God, this brings us to the paradox of the veils.
The created order, the physical world with all its density and distraction, is traditionally understood as that which hides God.
The sheer density of physical matter prevents us from seeing the spiritual light.
That is the standard view, yes.
So how can the physical world be both the veil that hides him and the exact same mirror that reveals him?
The Imam answers this with the startling compressed saying.
The veils do not veil him.
Think about the profound nature of this.
The very things that seem to conceal the divine, the heavy density of a stone, the labyrinthine complexity of a human face, the terrifying vastness of the night sky, cannot help but disclose the Creator.
Because they exist.
Yes, the veil itself is made of the very light it attempts to obscure.
Once the heart is polished, the realization zons that the veil that hides him is the exact same mirror that shows him.
The physical world is not an obstacle to the divine.
It is the very vocabulary through which the Nerulian speaks.
That is incredible.
God has made the remembrance a polish for the hearts by which they hear after being deaf and see after being blind.
We have traversed the anatomy of the heart, the rust of heedlessness and the blinding light of true sight.
But I turn now directly to you, sitting with this knowledge in the midst of your own life.
Look closely at the landscape of your own daily routine.
Amidst the relentless noise, the constant movement, the sheer velocity of your obligations, what has gone totally unremembered?
What spaces in your day are occupied by the walking dead?
And what is 1 simple costless practice of turning the heart, a silent invocation while walking to your car, a moment of presence before breaking bread?
You can begin this week to start rubbing away the rust.